pretty singer he's teamed up and now
he's ready to make his
sixth career start and his third
straight against the minnesota twins
and the twins have two on nobody out and
here comes rosario now rosario d.h
tonight over four last night did score a
run and the first pitch is swinging a
fly ball into right center field and
deep
back it goes deep it goes and gone three
run homer to the fountains for rosario
number seven of the year three batters
in
it's three nothing twins pitching
tonight is six start
as a record of four wins and one loss
will be the right-hander
randy dobnik one-on-one out for
hunter dozier see if the twins can get a
double play ball in this inning right
now
leading by three the 0-1 is the ground
ball to short yielded by polanco second
for one
the return is in time and right on cue
that's the 6-4-3
inning ending double play three-nothing
minnesota we go to any number two
and lamont wade leads off 2-1 to the
twins left-handed batting left fielder
and he swings and lines one softly back
of third base hit near the line
wade's going to round first base the
ball's in foul territory
he's going to make second base with a
lead-off double
franco thought about throwing his glove
at it so now it's up to polanco
who is already among the league leaders
in multi-hit games hoping to add to that
good pitch by singer lopez will throw
out polanco
so the lead-off man is on for alberto
mondesi
now monteci and modesty bunts hallelujah
and they've got no chance and gordon
takes second monday with a bunt base hit
and the royals have something going here
in inning number three
royals are batting with two down and two
on in the bottom of the third minnesota
leads three nothing
on an eddie rosario home run in the
first and now here's nikki lopez
avila sets up down and away and the 2-2
pitch a weak round ball tap first base
line picked up by dobneck fields and
throws him out
and that's the inning took a call third
strike in the first
inning and the royals have really turned
their fortunes around against ceno
and the 3-2 song on hit high near left
field and gordon
he's just going to turn around and watch
this one way out of here
off the hall of fame building behind
the bullpen wow
that was a blast how about 458
feet that's got to be one of the longest
ones
this year here's solaire he let off
the second inning with a walk
solaire is going to reach on catcher's
interference he just hit a comebacker to
dobnik but in doing so he
knocked the glove off of alex avila's
hand
so one on one out and now ryan mcbroom
he lined out to the second baseman a
rise
in the second inning and arise plays up
the middle right here here's the pitch
here and that's a ground ball
over the head of dobneck he let it go as
a rise
fields it steps on the bag and there is
the third double play turn for dobnek
here tonight
nobody left on base through four at
kauffman stadium four nothing minnesota
and now it will be gordon who went hard
up the middle
for a base hit in the third inning
alex goes to center field goal
alex gordon with a home run to straight
away center field
gordon gets the royals on the board with
a booming home run to center field
it's 4-1 minnesota gallagher at second
merrifield at first and the matter will
be nikki lopez
that's down the left-field line and
comes cam gallagher
to third goes merrifield second base
lopez and the royals
right now have the runners in scoring
position who could tie this game
so now the royals within two
and they have two men in scoring
position for hunter dozier
and a fastball lookout caught by domnick
right at his face
and he just flips the ball back over his
shoulder and heads back into the dugout
like no big deal wow that was a rocket
randy dobnik stays on for the sixth with
solaire mcbroom and franco coming up
solaire swings and a foul tip into
avila's glove and the count is one and
one
they call catcher's interference again
they did jorge soler is on his way to
first base
so ryan o'hearn is going to come up for
gallagher
checked his swing did he go strike three
so now they're gonna go against marwin
who most of his power three home runs
coming from the left side
big spot seventh inning and the 3-2
pitch he walked him nowhere near the
plate ball four
and that's a run 5-2 game bases still
loaded third walk of the inning
and now here comes jake cabe who has one
grand slam already this year
here's the 2-0 pitch and cave swings and
rolls it to the right side mcbroom
fields
he comes to the plate and it's in time
for the force on kepler
now there are two out and miguel's to
know is the batter
righty to righty delorean sets up away
the o2 pitch is swinging aligned
up the middle base hit center field one
run is in
rounding third heading home is gonzales
and he will score sliding the twins
indeed break it open
a note two mistake and sinone drives in
two more
and the twins take a 7-2 lead luis that
eyes the better first and third two out
pitching to luisa rise and he hits a
ground ball out to monday who will
backhand
race to the base at second and he barely
got there in front of
miguel ceneaux who has driven in two in
this inning
here's solaire minnesota leads 7-2
and the 3-2 pitch a swing and a missed
strike three on a change-up
twins have two on one out and now
polanco
3-1 pitch coming to polanco and he hits
a ground ball
the second looks like two second one
first base double play
rosario leads off still newberry
pitching and that ball is popped up left
side
franco has such a long way to go and
he's able to get there make a nice
backhanded catch
romo is throwing in the bullpen as
solaire comes up with two on and two out
and now a three-two count ninth inning
and the payoff pitch is swinging a
ground ball to third that's fair glove
by gonzalez will skip the throw across
in time and that's the game the twins
win 7-2